with all of that I am simply going to
turn this over to our first speaker
Kevin vhost I've introduced him a little
bit already is there anything else you
you know very grateful that you came I
have enjoyed your books quite a bit
myself I think all of you are going to
enjoy his talk all right and again thank
you Greg thank you Andy for setting this
up thank you all for for being here
this is the first time I get to talk to
a group of real-life Stoics I must admit
I wonder what you look like and I'm very
pleasantly pleasantly surprised how
intriguing that here we are all excited
and passionate about these dour stiff
lipped you know sour pusses in in some
of modern conceptions of what Stoics are
but we certainly know better my day
started in a perfect manner fit for a
stoic I meant the hotel I drove up from
Springfield Illinois and I'm greeted
with a flat tire
the first flat tire in all my many years
but Stoics our into relationships I had
good friends back Christine Fred
Flynn you live in this area and a Seneca
once said we shouldn't cultivate friends
so we'll have somebody to take care of
us when we're in need
we should cultivate friends so we can
take care of them when they're in need
and they are that kind of friend that
took care of me and I got me here today
so my talk is entitled 40 years on the
porch lessons ancient Stoics taught of
modern psychologists so to condense 40
years and a half an hour so I'm going to
really have to hit the ground rolling
but I will just give a few highlights of
course and I think one low light of my
experience throughout my life at the
Stoics and without them and then I talk
about lessons for a modern psychologist
but it's really broader than that
Epictetus had a big influence of me
becoming a psychologist but also a
public speaker not necessarily a good
one but a public speaker and a professor
a college professor
Epictetus played a big role there I
write a lot of books now and a person
who played a big role there was Seneca
and I'll explain in the course of the
talk how they did this but the other
great Stoics Marcus really is with
Sonia's Ruth has really given me all
kinds of benefits throughout my life
throughout the 40 years I've known them
in all kinds of different ways and I'll
highlight a few now
as we go through let's go back about 40
years in my late teens I was obsessed
with the love of two things we could
call it mind and body we could call it
wisdom and muscle we can call the
philosophy and body building or weight
lifting right and December 1978 these
two came together in the flesh in the
person of one man my friend and I drove
to st. Louis Missouri to see a seminar
by body builder named Mike Mentzer he
had just won the mr. universe title the
first man to never have a perfect score
he was expected to be the heir apparent
to arnold schwarzenegger but it didn't
kind of it kinda didn't really work out
that way but we go to his seminar when
our late teens at the time I was really
embodied what some modern psychologists
described as adolescent thinking
patterns people like that the professor
David Elkind talked about these
different aspects of adolescent
egocentrism infecting our adolescents
thinking we have these new reasoning
powers now hypothetical if then thinking
abstract abilities and it's like wow
we're approaching this world at all
these new ways we have these capacities
but we don't yet have the experience and
the knowledge base to really to really
rein it in but at that time I shared
some of those traits which include
things like a sense of invincibility
like nothing's going to harm you because
you're special right this concept of an
imaginary audience some teens have you
feel like everybody's looking about
yourself self-conscious you find out
later people are usually more focused on
themselves to spend too much time
worried about you but have that kind of
thing going on and it was relevant when
they call the personal fable the idea
that somehow our life is unique or
somebody never been anybody quite like
us who could really understand us you
know we're special that leads to that
sense of invulnerability
and one way that can manifest itself is
if you have a passion if you're into
music you're into sports you'll think
someday I'm going to be that guy you
know up on the stage you know if you got
a group of like a junior high basketball
players and the kids that are really
into it good at it they love it and you
ask for show hands how many of you are
gonna play in the NBA someday you're
likely to see a lot of hands you know
not knowing how selective that in
beds and actually years later when I did
some work for a group that certified
personal fitness trainers I did a little
survey of some of their trainers the one
they were that were into weightlifting
or bodybuilding and a majority of them
did think that they themselves one day
would be the actual top guy mr. Olympia
or the world waiting champion things
like that
so I had that so my buddy nine and a
bunch of other young people go to see
Mike man sir give this seminar and he's
mr. universe we're going there to find
out how we can do it he did some will be
mr. universe and early in this seminar
he tells us there's one thing you must
do is you're gonna become a world-class
bodybuilder and we're like this is what
we came here for drink motor oil no
problem workout 12 hours a day we got it
but he says no he said if you wanna be
the best body a whole class body but he
said you have to choose the right
parents how are we gonna do that you
know weight lifting training eating
right can do a lot to transform the body
for most people and if you're willing to
think steroids it can make you
freakishly big and powerful but no
matter how many steroids you take no
matter how much growth hormone you take
once you reach maturity you can't change
how long your clavicles are how wide
your shoulders are in the structure you
can't change how wide or narrow your
hips are to get that classic shape for
each one of the muscles of your body
like your biceps of two heads of the
biceps they attach from a very distance
to the elbow and if your biceps attached
very very low he had the potential to
develop massive arms like an Arnold
Schwarzenegger because the muscle can't
get wider they're thicker taller than it
is long if you look sure arm like I have
one one of the muscles attaches real low
and the other one there's again it's
higher so I thought once I listened to
mincer I realized well no I actually I'm
not gonna be mr. Lim ya know I guess
what dang you know but so he these would
be card teams called fractured fairy
tales and I say that he turned my
personal fable into a fractured fairy
tale and I'm how I'm not going to be the
best okay but there's a really relevant
line here from Epictetus when he talks
about Milo who's considered the father
of weightlifting the guy that lifted the
young calf
the calf got bigger my look kept lifting
it he kept getting bigger and stronger
until he was the the best Olympic
wrestling champion ever
but Athena says just because I can't be
a Milo doesn't mean I won't take care of
my body you know just because we can't
attain the highest in some field doesn't
mean we can't take care of ourselves I
try to be the best that we could
so my lesson for that seminar was I
realize okay I got to look at other
things in my life besides body building
my own genetic potential is a little bit
better for strength than it was for
muscles like competed in powerlifting
for some years and enjoyed that but now
years later as I look back upon this
experience in epictetus stoic terms I'm
thinking what's it meant sir teach me
that's something that I thought was
within my control was not nearly as in
my control as I thought so my own body
and in the the handbook of empathy is
the very first paragraph when he says
you know some things are up to us some
things are not up to us or under our
control not in our control one of the
first things he lists is our bodies is
something that we don't really have full
control over so I look back that he was
on to something so I mentor taught me
now I can't really control my body quite
to the extent but I thought it could and
that was an important lesson now mints
are also played an important role
because I lived and breathed these
muscle magazines Joe leaders muscle
builder muscle fitness all that immense
wrote his articles but he was also a bit
of an intellectual he loved philosophy
so he wrote about Friedrich Nietzsche
Bertrand Russell I ran I read a lot of
mine ran through him and after because
of that I started haunting these things
we used to have there still some around
it thing called bookstores reason where
you can go and see an executive book
saan the shelves and I found things like
popular works on philosophy will
Durant's story of philosophies is a
great historic and historian the story
of philosophy has booked the mansions of
philosophy it got me so intrigued in it
that by the time I went to college I
decided I wanted to be like Greg and
Daniel I wanted to be a philosophy
professor I wanted PhD philosophy but I
was so shy and such a homebody that the
local community college the Catholic
junior college and the state university
in my city
none of them had a philosophy major or
even a formal minor and I didn't I got
really good grades did well on
standardized
I never even thought about leaving town
so what did I do
thought well what's the second best
thing well they do have a psychology
major there's a lot of overlap so I
decided a major in psychology and take
as many philosophy courses as I could
just on the side but interestingly it
really wasn't in those philosophy
classes that I came across the Stoics it
was through my psychology coursework now
also one of those bookstores I would you
know look at the philosophy psychology
self-help I came across a book called a
new guide to rational living by Albert
Ellis and Robert Harper
Alber l is the founder of rational
emotive therapy and that was suddenly
has such a powerful impact on me that in
my junior and senior years when I was
living in on psychology I was taking a
clinical psych course and for my
research paper I decided to do it on
Alice's rational emotive there it was
the biggest research paper I ever did
outside of my thesis in a dissertation I
absorbed everything I could on Ellis
read all the books
this is pre-internet so I go to
something called psychological abstracts
trying to track down the articles go
find them on the shelves go copy em on
the ancient copying machines paying for
each page you know but anyway totally
absorbed Ellis everything you people
even eyes he made rational emotive songs
they never come across those I'm number
one he sang it to the tune of funicula
funiculi and he was making fun of being
obsessed even about having perfect
rationality and Angelo's I won't sing if
he says perfect perfect rationality
perfect rationality that is the only way
for me you know and stuff like that so I
mean I got into everything with Ellis
that same term I had abnormal psych
course so what did I write about there
well depression but of course Aaron
Beck's cognitive therapy of depression
so I also came absorbed in this other
alysus of psychologists Berit Beck was a
psychiatrist Ellis started this system
in the 50s Beck shortly after in the 60s
both of them acknowledged one of their
primary founding sources was Epictetus
and you know and they got a lot from
Edna Peters but the one line that they
both zoomed in or the both that caught
my attention the most was from the
handbook the fifth chapter where
epictetus says you know one translation
people just are disturbed not
things but by the views they take of
things okay and that had a both bed and
Ellis you know say how much they got out
of epic he does that idea and that was
mind-blowing for me it was kind of the
opposite of what mentor taught me mentor
taught me something I thought that was
in my control really wasn't
and this idea taught me things I didn't
realize I could control my own emotions
my ability to be upset or not to be shy
or not was actually within my control
now if you're familiar with Ellis he was
trained as in clinical psychologist at
his time for the first half of the 20th
century in psychiatry Freud and
psychoanalysts psychoanalysis those
people who have had the most sway and
part of the idea was if you're upset now
it's because some trauma you had when
you were a child in another bigger force
in psychology was behaviorism from
Pavlov's dogs to be of Skinner's pigeons
stimulus response you know we respond
because certain things on the outside
happened to us but Ellis said it came to
him that well sometimes childhood
traumas they certainly can set us up for
disturbance later in life he said but if
you're disturbed it's because of what
you keep telling yourself today about
that trauma that happened in the past
and I love the way he encapsulated
Epictetus
idea and what he called the ABC theory
of emotions some of you come across that
you know where it's like stimulus in
response but the a is activating event
the C is a consequence and Ellis says
you know what the activity event doesn't
necessarily produce an emotional
consequent the B which is the belief the
view the judgment makes a difference you
know one of the clearest examples Ellis
gave was imagine you're on a crowded bus
and this big huge man walks past you
stands squarely on your foot smashes
your big toe walk somebody without a
word of apology right what's gonna
happen you toes gonna hurt you probably
be angry you're gonna be angry stimulus
response activating events of
consequence he steps on my toe without
an apology I'm mad he says what happens
if you look though when you realize this
guy has very dark glasses and a white
cane right so he didn't do that on
purpose he was blind even he didn't even
know he did it
so he said would you still your toe it
still hurt but would you still be angry
wouldn't so you know part of the basis
of Summa techniques in cognitive therapy
are to make sure that your judgments of
situations your impressions are accurate
that they correspond with reality but it
goes beyond that because Ellis borrowing
from the Stoics would say well what if
he meant it but if it was on purpose
oh yeah your toaster do you really have
to be angry at him do you have to let
him ruin your day and they would say no
no because we are gonna encounter all
kinds of Justices in our life and we
can't train ourselves to not let other
people's actions disturb us even when
they're acting inappropriately as
empathy this might say you know another
person sure you can do anything went to
my paltry body but you can't control my
soul you can't control my my thoughts
and reactions so so that had a very very
profound impact on me it's the most
dramatic event where I saw the power of
this in action
I'll tell you about that Ellis said he
remembered the Stoics the power the
Stoics because when he's a young man he
wanted to talk to girls but he was too
shy so he studied the Stoics and he went
you know some big party approaches all
these girls most of them rebuffed him
but eventually he overcomes that problem
and can talk to girls he realized this
is not second such a catastrophe if they
reject him now in my teenage years that
wasn't a big problem for me I went to a
Catholic all-boys high school wasn't
around girls too much I was all focused
on my you know wisdom and muscle to me
girls were like goddesses on a pedestal
and I wasn't worthy to approach them
until I became mr. America then I would
then I would but the thing that got me
though was something I couldn't avoid
which was public speaking not as a known
actual public speaker but like in
classes often you'd have this darn
teacher professor that would insist at
the end of the term you present
something and I by nature was extremely
shy I have a ruddy complexion you
probably see it now I turn red very
easily especially if I but you know
colouring the time choking me but it was
so severe that I remember in high school
just just all boys around I should be
cured but I could sit there anything boy
wouldn't it be embarrassing if I turn
red right now just sitting here and sure
enough there was
they're just a oh I say he's terrible
before I knew the rationing motive
thought economist terrible but I read
methods in Ellis where he's borrowing
from the Stoics and even even it away
from the cynics I used two techniques to
get me over this the first is called
soon as I call it negative visualization
or I've heard Donna robertson gives a
Latin term pre-med Atacama Laura Moore
or preparing in advance for adversity
and here's how I did it borrowing from
Ellis paraphrasing him for public
speakeasy this imagine you're gonna give
a talk you get up there your force voice
falters you stutter you're trying to
crack a joke and nobody laughs you
realize you've spit on people in the
front row and if I have apologies you
looked at you realize your shoes don't
match on your fly's open
I said you know okay well maybe you say
maybe I'm the worst public speaker in
the world but somebody has to be right
so I thought about that I rehearse that
a lot but then whatever technique Ellis
called him shame attacking exercises in
people to go out and in purpose do
something embarrassing just to show yeah
I can survive this right and he would
talk about things like it was in New
York City where he was working go out
and walk up an Anna I want a leash like
it was a dog or just going in elevator
and face back instead of front you know
things like so and there's actually a
story you know greatness talking about
zeno of kid iam there's a story like in
diogenes laërtius life of you know like
the second page he said that he was
being taught under crepes for like his
Crotty
not crates and so crates it's good
brought these and Socrates right but
yeah he was studying under Kratos who is
a cynic philosopher and he realized that
scene was very easily embarrassed he
wanted a carom of that so he made a walk
around the city carrying this big pot of
lentil soup and it said that when he
realized that Xena was embarrassin tried
to hide it Katya took his staff and
special so the soup went over his legs
and Xena ran away he said he said what
are you running away for you little
Phoenicians nothing terrible has
befallen you
so actually the story there in our
founders II know that this technique was
used on him so he what did I do
well it didn't involve a banana or a pea
soup but I had to give a talk in a
psychology class and I remember it was
on Alfred Korzybski general semantics
which was another area of thought that
that Ellison had borrowed from before I
gave that talk I just got in front of it
it was a small I mean a fraction of this
size of crap I said I want to apologize
in advance if you see me turning red or
sweating if my voice cracks I said if
you can see my heart pounding beneath my
chest at the time I was really into
bench pressing and wear tight shirts I
did that Arnold Schwarzenegger thing so
I made a complete fool of myself you
know a spectacle in myself and then I
got on with it and seriously from that
point on I've really not been nervous
giving any public talk with the
exception I almost did two weeks ago you
know I'll tell you before I finish why
that was but it didn't really I really
did not get that nervous about that but
but it wasn't if I saw this is amazingly
effective even for me a person who
naturally shy is me that this could make
a real a real difference in my life so
you know moving along I go through
college survey for my bachelor's I got a
job working disability claims for the
Social Security Administration though it
was a state job in an Illinois I don't
know how it is in Wisconsin or your
state but some people said the state
worker was an oxymoron you know they
don't do much work but I was one for 32
years but we did we had a tremendous
caseload of mental and physical
disability cases and they kept all kinds
of statistics on us how long it take us
to do each case how accurate we were
coming quality assurance returns we got
so many people found this very stressful
and sometimes we were held accountable
for things that were outside of our
control one simple example if a person
files a disability claim they have not
seen a doctor recently we are obligated
to set them up with an exam to see a
doctor
but sometimes they would fail and know
you're supposed to come there is a
no-show
subdued ears are totally angry well now
my processing time is going to go up and
they call that person and they chew him
out
you know you better attend this Nixon
why do you
going all this and I would never do that
I was like calmly call and try to
explain to them you know we I give you I
give you one more try so if you can't
make it for some good reason next time
you have to call me you know otherwise
I'll have to finish your case without it
so basically if this is up to you
whether you make it or not you're not
gonna upset me one way or the other I
mean I didn't say that but that's the
way I thought about it but let you know
see the exact consequences so so people
actually comment how can you do that how
can you be so nice to those people well
there was no need for the contrary
through the years to the Stoics helped
me when I became a supervisor I kind of
came into a small group that had all
kinds of turmoil going on they said one
of the guys there used to have shouting
matches with the old supervisor and I
really kind of I didn't preach the
Stoics to do to my own employees at all
I often brought a book with me to work
and it would often be Epictetus or
Seneca Aurelius and a few very bookish
co-workers would talk to me and I would
actually talk to them about the stores
but mostly was just trying to you know
trying to give a comment in the sphere
my relationships of course the Stoics
have helped there I won't go into that
any depth because I know Greg and Andy
you're going to deal with that when I
went back for my doctoral degree in
psychology after I was working full time
the Stoics helped me there when I did a
limited amount of psychotherapy I used
mostly Albert Ellis's material and stoic
ideas when I did one-on-one counseling
with people but most of my work was in
an Alzheimer's Center doing cognitive
testing for people to see if there had
to mention or not or people had
different kinds of brain injuries we
also did Studies on normal aging what
happens to be memory and reason the
abilities and stuff as you get older and
I didn't think a whole lot about the
Stoics at that time but as I look back
on it now I tell you the older I get the
more I appreciate Marcus Aurelius and
I'm 58 I believe I'm as old as he ever
got which was 58 but but you know many
is still let's talk about being aware be
aware that we're gonna die someday right
keep that in mind so live while you have
a chance here to live on earth but it
really is and maybe the other stupid I
don't recall it but it really is in
several places
it says not only that he says but be
aware you may lose your faculties
someday
you may lose your powers of reason while
you're still alive so you kind of make
the most of them while you're here so
you know to me that was a profound
insight a low-light it really wasn't
where the Stoics failed me it's where I
I kind of failed the Stoics is I got
close to finishing my doctoral degree in
psychology there's a special program the
state of Illinois set it up for us of a
bunch of it's like 30 of us who went
through this program at the same time
many people were already working as
psychologists with master's degrees they
wanted to get that that doctorate and go
on down to other things and you know
it's very competitive we were very very
focused about this I worked the whole
time through it I did it except for the
dissertation internship here but by the
time I finish this like men I so focus
on the externals I want to be
psychologists I want to be called doctor
I went that salary that comes with the
psychologists position so the first job
I took first time is offered I took it
relocated my family my wife left her job
take our kids to a different place I'd
really never failed in anything in my
life and it had full of hubris you know
I took a job in a Developmental Center I
have no background in it when I got
there the place was guy kind of going
into a civil war they had a new head of
psychology and they were like factions
they thought his new ideas were crazy
and some didn't and there were so many
unreasonable demands I found that people
some people like even fabricating the
records I don't have time to do this
therapy with this group of people like
I'm supposed to do but I'll put a note
about the session and I can never do
that so it caused me great you know
moral strain to know I couldn't even I'm
no way I could fake it so the irony was
I Mara one day I thought I might take a
little of it leave I feel I starting
into a depressive episode
I got opened up my mail and it was from
the licensing board in psychology in
Indiana I went over to Indiana to take
my test and I had the highest score in
the state I set my school's record but
at the same time I was depressed and I
was trying to figure out how do I get
back to my old job that did not require
the doctor great and actually did it
took a voluntary demotion
you know God Providence works in amazing
ways I was able to get my old job back
my wife got her spec I got my part
College teaching back but I didn't go
through about a six-month period where
ice to press anything work out which
that tells you I was genuinely depressed
thank God I mean it's the only time
since then but the guys are kind of I
was so busy I kind of didn't employ
those stoic ideas that that used to be
so important to me better move along six
years later I'm 43 years old I'm reading
a line in Seneca and if you'll excuse my
horrible Latin the language
Nikhil me news is himani aku potty
qualms where we're immersed ran slated
as the busy person is least busy with
living I took it like Socrates idea the
unexamined life was not worth living I'm
just doing too much
now I to me tasks so I was working
full-time I went to school and I mostly
work full-time I talked college teach
college courses part-time so I cut back
a lot and the next thing I knew I delve
more into the Stoics I dealt in the st.
Thomas Aquinas I had like a religious
reconversion I've been an atheist for 25
years I found myself being convinced in
the reasonableness of God and within the
first year I wrote the first of 19 books
I've been right over the next 15 years
I've done one one book before this time
but Seneca that was just kind of like
the impetus there that got going now as
for my books I'm gonna need that why
down here just a bit but I did the one
book directly about the Stoics the porch
and the cross my sonís Rufus Epictetus
ascending that Marcus Aurelius a brief
biography chapter a brief summary of
some of their teachings and a legacy
chapter that looked at how the Christian
world took them in other parts of the
world took them to and I was asked
recently on the Sunday stoic podcast it
hasn't aired yet but somebody wanted to
know when I talked about stoicism
amongst Christian and Catholic audiences
you know what is the response bit and I
had to say so far nothing but good now
for other things I've written I know if
you people think you've made a mistake
if you actually had they're often not
hesitant to let you know that and there
are certain topics that I know are very
very controversy when you pull from some
like Eastern religions in some Catholic
and Christian circles things like yoga
certain kinds of mindfulness you'll
generate controversy but in my writings
on the stoic I have never
never had a comment some of the positive
comments while prominent Catholic author
told me he had a friend who was a
Protestant in a more fundamentalist
denomination that kind of denigrated the
value of reason is faith alone reason is
depraved you know and he said that
friend told it later
he abandoned Christianity became a stoic
II said he couldn't understand it and he
said after he read the portion the cross
in fountain o came across the Stoics
person he understood it now
he understood now because if you think
reason is youthful if you know it's
worthless and depraved and you read the
Stokes for first time you're probably
having a big surprise you know because
reason can go a long way can be very
noble can be very good another Catholic
priest very popular author gave me an
endorsement for some II read Epictetus
he said man he was intrigued by a
Batista ghost that is one cool dude
another man a deacon Eve ma'aming he
wanted him by a batch of the books for
his parishioners he goes before I read
your book he said I considered myself
you know Catholic but also a minimalist
he said that to read your book I thought
I'm actually more the stoic even you
know that a minimalist so very very
positive responses there and again it's
one of the things I loved about the
stories I loved them when I considered
myself an atheist I loved them no less
you know when I when I came back to the
Catholic Church I imagined in this room
here there's a whole variety of
religious beliefs or lack of beliefs
people who are secular soirée theists or
agnostics and there's just so much
common good there in the Stoics that we
can all find different aspects that we
can put into use and as part of the
reason I had such a profound influence
in my life so I need to wipe down here
before I see if you have any questions I
did mention I almost got nervous before
a talk
lucky for two I haven't got nervous
today when I walked out there and saw
that flat tire so it wasn't about the
talk just about how am I gonna get my
car taken care of and get here you know
but but if the one was two weeks in
there day ago Nashville Tennessee at the
Grand Ole Opry land resort which my wife
didn't go with me for that one I wish
she did because they didn't realize
haven't been there it's like a
Disneyland you know under one roof it's
a little bit every
she would she would have done okay but
anyway it was for the Catholic Medical
Association 900 medical doctors and in a
like people's social workers and nurses
and pharmacists and things and their
whole topic was physician heal thyself
coping with medical burnout and I just
saw the sort of a little bit nervous
because it wasn't my specialty or I'm
not an MD Don the psychologist but they
asked me to do that like a year and a
half advance so I did my own work you
know I studied and I came to find that
they talked about three main symptoms
involved in professional burnout and
especially medical burnout the first
they call emotional exhaustion you're
overwhelmed emotionally you're drained
the second a sense of deep
personalization you don't feel connected
with yourself or you see a patient just
as a body and not as a person or you
feel like a robot yourself they would
say the third is a diminished sense of
personal accomplishment you don't think
you're confident where you're not
achieving anything worthwhile so I broke
my talk into three parts I said I'm
gonna treat mind body and soul and we do
in terms of virtues and intellectual
virtue which was prudence of practical
knowledge of virtue for the body part
the physical virtue fortitude which
means strength I talked about the
parallels with mental strength and
actual strength training which they
found to be helpful for people who have
job stresses and make sure your physical
exercise the third component for
accomplishment I focused on the
Christian view of charity or loved have
I need these are Catholic doctors what
are you trying to accomplish if you're
trying to show love to people by using
the best of your skills to help them
then how can you be a failure if that's
really what you you know what trained us
so anyway but the first part emotional
exhaustion is even considered the
central component of burnout sometimes
when they test that's just the one they
test for and what better way to deal
with being emotionally overwhelmed or
train than stoicism right so I saw I
threw some Epictetus at them gave them
some what I told you the cognitive
therapy Ellis connection and then to try
to give them a take home now I told him
I didn't want to give them a
prescription because their medical
doctors might be very presumptuous for
me to do
does anyone familiar with Steak and
Shake restaurants a little black and
white they ever think all the take home
a sack it's all one word for your take
out you so I'm gonna give you a take
home a sack a practical application I
say you could call this it's kind of too
negative visualization thing we talked
about our stress inoculation is more of
a
medically oriented turn prepare yourself
in advance for your stress so I gave him
a line I said this comes from a man who
had the most stressful occupation
problem perhaps in all of history his
doctor was Galen one of the founders of
Medicine in his profession was that you
know you would be burned out if you live
long enough his profession of course was
a Roman Emperor in his name was Marcus
Aurelius and here's how I said that he
recommends he said save yourself every
morning
today I will encounter the busybody the
famous the overbearing right the
treacherous the envious the unneighborly
all this has befallen them because they
do not know good from evil but I who
know the nature of good that is
beautiful and evil that it's ugly and
the nature of the wrongdoer that it is
akin to me not as coming from the same
blood or the same seed but is sharing an
intelligence in a spark of the divine I
can either be harmed by them because
nobody else's actions can debase me nor
can I be angry and hate my kinsmen for
we were brought into existence for
cooperation as are the the hands in the
feet the eyelids the upper and lower
rows of teeth
so therefore to act against another is
that contrary to nature and we act
against another when we show resentment
or reversion version by lashing out or
by turning away and it kind of suggests
that actually it's an exercise I do
myself as often as I can and I suggest
then we form their own version of that
statement for that stresses they're
gonna encounter in their own age
the patient who saw commercials gonna
tell them what kind of medicine they
should be taking that you know whatever
it is and I say to in our modern times
all this stuff about the busybody and
the tractors that still applies right
you're gonna find them and you're even
going to find it before you get to work
because on they waited your job you're
going to have a tailgater you're going
to that person that drives so slow they
putz through the red light when you're
stuck right you know but all this so
anyway that wasn't one less than I tried
to give him the doctors and it seemed
that they appreciated that the stoic
insights there so I want to sum up and
just say I just give you a few of the
countless lessons that that
I learned from the Stoics some I've been
able to apply not not perfectly some I
haven't for my own case now you know
Stokes talk about like a morning
exercise and an evening reflection
Senecas big on evening reflection I
don't do that because of my head hits
the pillow I'm gone I'm a morning person
so I do a morning one of the things I do
I try to read something from the Stoics
themselves and/or a modern book what I'm
going through right now is a daily stoic
Ryan holidays book anyone so there's
that one
today's happens to topic happens be
something about log so very appropriate
for the talk we have coming up
yesterday's very catching too because
there's even some humor in the Stoics
markets are really a sense an honest
good person should be like a smelly goat
you know you know and when is in your
presence so he said instead versions
they say like a person would be young
but this one said smelly I like so what
a maxim I'm gonna be like a smelly go
what does he mean now that you just stop
using your deodorant they said don't go
around saying to tell you the truth or
to be honest or have you straight is
this just be honest just be true there's
a little show through in your demeanor
you know see so people will know but
anyway okay so that's just that that's
it that's the take-home assess be like a
smelly go but anyway I think and I want
to thank you I'll take any questions and
I will say that hopefully I will
continue to grow and learn from the
Stoics every day for the rest of my life
until as Epictetus puts it the captain
calls for me so thank you very much
yes charlie yeah I guess I have a
question you know the value of reason
that the Stoics and alert philosophies
use what have you learned and what it'd
be fun in your own life the limits of
the reason I say that is that you know
reason is a very good tool but it's
administered by an imperfect being
meeting me yes and almost in almost
every situation we don't know everything
that's going to happen you know every
almost every decision we make is based
on Summit semi incomplete information so
you know what's your experience with the
value of reason and however they yeah
that is an excellent question
my doctor school is the Adler School of
University Coll of Professional
Psychology in Chicago and Alfred Adler
Albert Ellis would later say he was
named Alerian I hadn't had any ideas
that were consistent with the Stoics and
he used to go in like people would give
him a clinical case and he would say all
here's what he thinks all the dynamics
are but then at the very end you would
say something I can do something that's
kind of all these contours and of course
everything could also be different and
actually in a written essay once I use
that as my concluding line here's my
take on it of course maybe everything is
also different here but but there's that
idea right where do the best we can with
our rational capacity but we're gonna
have that sort of the reserve clause we
know we may be wrong we're gonna be open
to further correction now coming from I
do know from the Catherine position from
Thomas Aquinas we also take in
consideration faith the idea that faith
does not something that conflicts with
reason but but possibly God can implant
us with things that go beyond our own
capacity coming from him so for me I
take you know same reason like an like
elseis thing even out what Ellis's we
shouldn't strive for perfect rationality
because we ain't gonna get it you know
we need to be aware that there are
limits there but it is so value so
viable to strive to develop it but again
you know being open watching for that
feedback to find what you've been
mistaken and then we try to grow is
itcool the reserve clause
well what is they do use term reserve
clause but I can't hear but that's the
content
my framing of saying oh yes yeah
the good Mart willing the creek don't
rise that kind of thing yeah yeah like
for your own actions you're gonna say
I'd like to do this right home for sure
if I will you know
something they come up that I don't
expect might get a flat tire thank you
[Music]
favorite color blue this is the velocity
of a South African swallow I don't know
they ever power that this a lot it
definitely used to be the squad the
barbell squat but you know I've been
doing them since I was like 15 years old
and fifty no 58 not mention so I have
some issues when I do either low or a
high bar spot my lower back and I had a
knee problem for a long long time right
now
I found it makes if I can do front
squats I feel great
they're very therapeutic of my knees I
keep everything aligned but benchpress I
love by love overhead press more
deadlift I just did them yesterday and
I'm not feeling it I like that question
but you know there's nothing to it just
about training in general you answer at
the powerless which is benchpress and
and and squat and deadlift but there of
course now there's so many different
ways you can train your body with the
strength training exercises with
machines you know with the CrossFit type
of thing my friend Pat Flynn is one of
the world's experts on kettlebell
training there's all these things we can
do out here to to train our bodies and
that's one lesson I actually have
employed from the Stoics I wrote an
article called show me your shoulders
the stoic workout for the site a few
years ago barring that line from
Epictetus and he's saying if I go to an
athlete and say I'm gonna see the
results your training says don't look at
my weights he says go to you and your
weights
I want to see your shoulders I'm gonna
see what those weights have done for you
you know those folks have a lot of good
insights
Seneca even has a line talking about he
says there are there are simple brief
exercises you can do that will wear
yourself out in a minimum of the time
and then let you get back to more
important things
it happens that training like mentor
taught me about what's called hip
training high-intensity training which
is exactly that designed to be short and
brief and leave time in your life to do
other things so it's almost almost
anything you talk about has a stoic
connection
did I say this my book fit for eternal
life for a Catholic publisher on the
back it shows three books surrounded by
a jump rope the Bible Thomas Aquinas is
set at Summa Theologica and Epictetus is
discourses I didn't ask them to do it
the publisher happened to be a PhD in
philosophy and they saw that I had cited
Epictetus so often they put it back yes
[Music]
oh no that's that's heavy have you any
stuff there
the predestination and oh and I could
mess this up great may have much more
teeth than me and this actually but I
think one way of looking at the the
predestination would be that the God is
all-knowing and powerful I mean there's
no yesterday and today and tomorrow for
him it's all present to him so there's
things that for us are in the future
that haven't happened yet and God would
already would already know that or with
this I guess permissive will will allow
us to choose one way or another so the
way I see it in the Stoics there's a
sense of determinism with them too but
there is that realm that our choices
enter into the picture and make a
difference so I think that for both the
Stoics and Thomas Aquinas though maybe
you know see if we could see things
through the mind of God you already know
that the result but within our real
lives live we do have choice we have we
have freewill and we can make a
difference in our lives
see now that always makes it very very
very hard for me just one I might say
the Summa Theologica and here's why if
you're familiar to Thomas Aquinas the
greatest work a million and a half words
three or four thousand pages I order the
Latin English hardcover edition in the
shipping weight was 32 pounds okay
seriously yeah yeah it's like the
quantity out in Wyoming you're some
blackfyres
friars translation we can literally look
on Amazon 32 pound and part of the
reason I love it so much though is that
you know I love the scripture I love
Aristotle
I once call myself an Aristotelian stoic
Albertine Thomas you know I mean have
all these influences but because when
you get Aquinas he wasn't just I'm
thinking this stuff up out of my head he
he borrowed a widely from from other
traditions and one in particular was
Seneca it's not believe Thomas was was
well versed in Greek but the course
Seneca relent Thomas cite Seneca when he
talks about the passion of anger what it
means a mean to get anger how could it
how can it become a vice or sin he can't
even try to reconcile Aristotle in
Seneca anger he talks about clemency in
fighting the context of the virtue of
temperance or self-control in terms of
administering a punishment to someone
how do we do that and they're in the
right way to show clemency to try to
correct them and not to harm them he
cites Seneca most profusely when talking
about the virtue of gratitude how it
relates to justice
he just cites Seneca actually more than
Aristotle and more than agustin in more
than the scriptures so for that reason I
probably picked a Summa Theologica
because it's almost like you know an
encyclopedia and compendium of other
books I would choose Aristotle's
Nicomachean ethics you know the letters
of Seneca or epictetus handbook or the
meditation so he doesn't specifically
cite a mechanism or really as there are
many thoughts there that would be
consistent so not that question but a
very tough one yes
[Music]
okay and I know I'm not definitely not
the only one I did this Sunday stoical
podcast with Steve Kerr fit-out in
Arkansas in fount of the hues of
Catholic - I'm sure there's a lot of
Catholics out there I'd say the getting
bomb and stoicism himself you know if
you're in this area especially know we
talked to Craig or Dan or these folks
and they'll get you connected as far as
you know because again they're multiple
Catholics out there doing it like I said
my own book the porch of the Cross I
kind of give it from a Catholic
perspective I prepare for comparing with
sonia's Rufus some of his statements to
sections of the Catechism the Catholic
Church I talked about the influence of
st. Thomas Aquinas I talked about what
Greg talked about the Christianized
versions used for monks for epictetus
this handbook things like that so I'd
say they're on a personal level talk to
these folks and in terms of your your
reading if I can be so presumptuous you
might want to look at my fortune the
cross but of course there's also just
tons of good books out there now by
Stoics some of the main people writing
are from either philosophers or
psychologists and people who are neither
but there's just a wealth of information
out there if you like to talk to me
personally if I get a chance today
yes reincarnation
afterlife
Kharma well if you target coming in
terms of like cause and effect or in
this life like what goes around comes
around stuff I think there's a lot of
sense there personally personally I
don't there I subscribe more to the
domestic view of the way the mind in the
body relate and compounding us as one
person and if you didn't have the same
body it really wouldn't be the same so
you're not just a soul in a body like
the soul you're an insult body so
personally I don't and when I come
across things in the stoke that I
disagree with I just say well you know
interesting you know I'll try to see
where they're coming from but I don't
necessarily incorporate that into my my
worldview but I take note of it you know
try to respect it and see where it's
coming
[Music]
[Applause]
you